the mystery of a little girl who seemed
to vanish into thin air
[Music]
a tragedy that gripped the world
what happened to madeleine mccann has
been a puzzle for more than a decade
the answer could lie hundreds of miles
from where the child was last seen
[Music]
madeleine was nearly four when she
disappeared in 2007.
this last photograph of her has become
one of the best-known news images of our
time
kate and jerry mccann had brought their
daughter and her younger twin siblings
on a week's holiday to portugal to prior
deluge a quiet resort on the algarve
coast on the third of may at around 8 30
pm the mccanns left apartment 5a on the
corner of the ocean club complex to meet
their friends at a tapas bar 80 yards
away
that agreed to look in on each other's
children in half-hour intervals
at 9 30 one of kate and jerry's friend
checked on the children and said
everything was fine
10 pm
kate mccann finished eating and returned
to the apartment madeline was missing
and her terrified mother raised the
alarm
she's
answers to the name of madeleine or
maddie there were a few police and
police dogs that were searching the area
but there doesn't seem to be much
activity at the moment
[Music]
at first madeleine's disappearance was
treated as a missing person rather than
a criminal case
that meant the apartment wasn't sealed
off for weeks with potentially vital
forensic evidence lost
in the first week police chased false
leads and sightings
and the mccanns held numerous press
conferences
words cannot describe the anguish
and despair that we are feeling as the
parents of our beautiful daughter
madeleine
eleven days in expat robert murat was
formally questioned as a suspect much
later he was cleared of all suspicion
he lived close to where madeleine
vanished and had been helping police as
a translator
her parents prayed for their daughter's
return
they met the pope he blessed a
photograph of madeleine
thousands of supporters tied yellow
ribbons as symbols of hope
[Music]
as the world looked on
a devastating twist the mccann's parents
became our guido's suspects
two specialist dogs one to detect dead
bodies the other traces of blood were
brought over from britain at the request
of the portuguese police
the dogs reacted to something in the
mccann's apartment
and in their rental car which wasn't
hired until three weeks after madeleine
disappeared
four months after their daughter
vanished from her bed
her parents were questioned over
suspicions madeleine had died
accidentally at their hands
they were released
with no charges ever brought
soon after kate and jerry left portugal
and flew home with their two younger
children
whilst it's heartbreaking to return to
the uk without madeleine
it does not mean we're giving up our
search for her
after an appeal by the mccanns to the
then prime minister david cameron they
say that there is new evidence new leads
to follow new things to be done it was a
case that
did shock and still shocks the nation
scotland yard was then called in
and their own investigation operation
grange was launched
detective chief inspector andy redwood
led a team which identified 600
individuals of some interest
six years after madeline's disappearance
detectives used the bbc's crimewatch
show to announce they had made a
breakthrough
reanalyze and reassess everything
accepting nothing this artist's
impression had been considered crucial a
man seen carrying a child 45 minutes
before madeline was discovered missing
a night crash that was operating from
the main ocean club reception and eight
families had left 11 children in there
and one particular family we spoke to
they themselves believed that they could
be the tanner sighting we're almost
certain now that this sighting is not
the abductor scotland yard's focus was
on a different suspect seen carrying a
child towards the beach at around 10 pm
two theories were in play a planned
abduction or a burglary gone wrong
a series of suspects were considered and
then ruled out i confirmed that i'm a
witness not a suspect
so basically i'm just going to wait for
the investigation to see what's going on
a portuguese investigation focused on a
series of sex attacks on young sleeping
children in resorts along the coast
there were some 50 odd files on sexual
predators that had been forwarded
to the portuguese police by the british
police that the british were not
convinced had all been thoroughly
investigated
on the 10-year anniversary of
madeleine's disappearance a new appeal
which led to the german authorities
getting involved
i know we have a significant line of
inquiry
which
is worth pursuing and because it's worth
pursuing
it could provide an answer a suspect
known as christian b
was revealed on the 3rd of june
2020.
a day later a german prosecutor
confirmed madeleine's disappearance was
being treated as murder
on the 12th of july portuguese police
started searching disused wells close to
prior deluge where madeline disappeared
and just over ten days later police in
portugal reopened their investigation
into the rape of an irish woman who
believes her attacker may have been
christian bee
another dramatic development came on the
20th of april 2022.
christian b was made an arguedo a formal
suspect by portuguese authorities
the move was probably to head off the
statute of limitations in portuguese law
which prevents people from being
prosecuted for serious crimes after 15
years
it was just under two weeks before the
15th anniversary of madeleine's
disappearance
but sky news has found out exclusively
that christian bee insists he has an
alibi
the german drifter says he was many
miles from the scene having sex in his
campervan with a young woman who would
back his alibi
he even says they were stopped and
photographed at a police roadblock as he
drove her to the airport the next day
german police say christian b hasn't
told them anything and they can work
only with the evidence they have
the world has not forgotten madeleine
new sightings in different countries
will have helped keep the family's hopes
alive
madeleine's parents have always said
they've seen no evidence to suggest
she's come to any harm you have to keep
going and especially when you've got
other children involved and you know
some of that is subconscious i think you
your mind and body just take over to a
certain extent one of our goals
obviously ultimately finding madeleine
um was to ensure that sean and emily
have a very normal happy and fulfilling
life before madeleine
was taken we felt we'd managed to
achieve a little perfect nuclear family
of five
and we had that for a short period and
you adapt and you have
a new normality and unfortunately for us
our new normality at the minute is a
family form
an obsession with her disappearance the
public's fascination with this mystery
perhaps an acknowledgement of the risks
you take as a parent
the mccanns have always accepted they
were wrong to leave their children on
their own
but they've never wavered in their
belief
madeleine would one day be found
from my point of view
you know
somebody knows what's happened whatever
it takes for as long as it takes you
know but there's still hope that we can
find